joining me today is an iranian-born
shia muslim scholar and the president of
the islamic association of
south australia imam mohamed tawidi
welcome to the reuben report
hello dave thank you for having me which
one of us is going to be in more trouble
for doing this
well i'm already in enough trouble so
hopefully we can share that part
all right so two interesting things have
happened even before we
start this conversation first you said
to me in the green room
nothing is off limits you said ask me
the hardest questions you can possibly
do
i appreciate that as an interviewer and
that's it's a refreshing thing to hear
i just thought it was interesting that
you even said that to me because it's
like
you know a lot of times people just want
to come in and say what they want but
but you
you want to be challenged you want to go
to those places
correct i've had many interviews over
400 interviews in the last two years
whether they be on radio or television
or youtube
and i just feel that many people
give us special treatment just because
i'm muslim and even though they know
that i do have some conservative views
such as
the border on border protection national
security
but even then they still want to give me
that special treatment so i made that
request publicly as well
yeah okay please don't be nice there's a
lot of information i can share
all right well i'm probably going to be
nice to you but i will try to get to
some of the hard stuff don't worry it's
right here that's number one and then
number two
right before we started you requested
that normally right behind you there
we have a little thing of wine bottles
that are right behind you
and you ask that we removed it just out
of your direct shot behind you because
you just don't want to get
any any bonus hate let's say which i
think is
i sympathize with that position but it's
also sort of interesting because you
take all of these very controversial
positions and it's like oh well they got
him with some wine bottles it's like
yes well these issues serve the
extremist agenda
if the extremists can obtain an image of
me beside a wine bottle
or a or in a bar for example then they
can easily discredit me as a muslim
imam because muslims don't drink and i
don't drink either
but they can easily stick that
accusation when they have a picture
of me being close to a wine bottle and
they want that and i'm not going to
allow them to do that how thrilled are
they going to be that you're in the home
studio of a gay jew this cannot be a
that's got to be worse than wine bottles
what's the list well i'd say 80 upset
yeah they won't be happy they won't be
happy at the fact that uh you have a
large audience as well
so they try to silence me and you've got
people that try to silence you as well
so but i'm happy to be here gay or not
to you or not i'm happy to be here yeah
and i'm happy you're here and and all
right so let's let's let it fly so first
just tell me a little bit about your
history you grew up in iran until you
were about 12 years old right correct
yeah i was uh in iran
for the first 12 years of my life and
then we traveled to australia
we landed in 1995. my father
is a prominent muslim faith leader as
well and imam
and he traveled from melbourne which we
first landed
to western australia and established the
first shia muslim mosque
and it was originally a church he called
the it was called saint mary
church so he left the name saint mary
mosque
wow yeah out of respect for the the
greater christian majority
and uh you see my father i learned
tolerance from him
he didn't have that belief in him that
oh it's a church it's filthy we can't
turn it into a mosque
it was for sale the people will come the
mosque none of these terrorist attacks
had happened
people were fine with mosques and so
the first mosque was erected in uh in
perth western australia and uh basically
i
grew up there until 2007.
i was raised amongst scholars and
islamic teachings in a very conservative
muslim family i come from so what does a
conservative muslim family mean a
conservative muslim family
goes the extra mile to be extra
religious
so we wouldn't even go to banks or
shopping centers that played music
let alone listening to music ourselves
whereby other muslims would not listen
to music because it's banned
in mainstream islamic jurisprudence
they would still go to shopping centers
and you know attend music lessons
in in school but we were very uh
very conservative i couldn't wear
anything shiny or anything like that
such as watches or necklace or anything
like that what was that like for you
just as a young person that
you know i'm sure you knew that music
was out there i'm sure you knew movies
were out there and video games and the
rest of it
yeah i had never been to a cinema until
i was
20 years old well i've never actually
completed a movie
now i'm not here to uh uh play the
oppressed person and it was harsh and
i i know you are not me but i'm gonna be
i try to be as honest as i can
i didn't know what that life was like so
the life i was living was very normal
it was this is how life is to me i
didn't know there was another life and
in fact
when i first moved to a
a public australian school
i was shocked that
we actually had people that were not
muslim because the school i grew up in
was
a i was raised in initially completed my
initial studies in western australia
they were it was a private muslim school
also a conservative atmosphere so
the house was a conservative atmosphere
school was a conservative
atmosphere up until 2007 i go back to
iran and then you've got sharia law
everywhere
wow so i've never actually had time to
be open to the rest of the world and
just accept
everyone and that happened after you
know my family was oppressed by isis in
2014
when i was still there studying and it
just hit me
that this can't be the way we were
supposed to live
do you remember the moment that it hit
you was it was it finally going to
another school no i was
an islamist a fundamentalist and an
extremist as well yeah okay so i'm going
to later in the interview let's define
some of those terms because i think
people get lost a little bit and the
difference between islamist jihadists
fundamentalists etc okay so put it to
you this way i wouldn't have sat with
you
yeah uh before 2014.
i wouldn't have i wouldn't even shake
your hand because
that was the mentality that i had
complete rejection of the west
and i was walking in in the holy city of
karbala
it's a shia muslim stronghold
and the speakers of the
sacred shrine of imam hussain
announced that mosul which is mosul
the iraqi city close to baghdad had
fallen
under the authority of isis
and that's what an hour away from where
i was
so that's when it really hit me and then
as i tried to leave the country
uh i found a lot of struggle because
airports were now blocked these guys
were shooting down airplanes
and the australian passport that i had
saved me
i was given priority and i returned back
to australia
but before all of this happened my uncle
was
kidnapped burnt alive who served in the
iraqi army
and we had to go receive his body from
baghdad so
this whole scenario woke me up and when
i came to australia
i saw that hang on muslims are killing
muslims
i've been interrogated in iran for
several times for my views and
and opinions and the muslims in
australia
are playing the victim card crying
islamophobia
so then i started to form diplomatic
relations and public relations to combat
extremists
so what was it like right when you got
onto the scene right when you started
being more public about this because
i'll be very honest with you when i
first saw you
on twitter and you were tweeting about
some of these things i thought
i i can't well so immediately everybody
was like reuben you've got to have
the imam tuition everybody was saying
and i was like this guy just came out of
nowhere i can't just magically
sit down with him i'm not perfectly
versed in all of these things obviously
and i don't want to be
used as a pawn basically so
what was it like as you started talking
about these things from the inside
community
and the outside community okay the
inside community knew who i was
because of my lineage because i
descend from the the companions of
prophet muhammad
one of the early converts from
christianity into islam
and you know shared their wealth and
their military and their tribes and
everything
military power with prophet muhammed and
they went through
throughout arabia in all the wars and
i've written in my book that they're
terrorists
so i my prominent lineage my father
my grandfather and also the fact that i
was close to the grand ayatollahs and i
was ordained publicly as an imam
so the inside world of islam knew who i
was yeah
and i still had facebook i still had
twitter
you know very humble following a basic
following and but i was still known
not the big twitter star you are now
well
life changes so what happened was the
muslims
knew me and there are many forums now
dating back to 2008 that
discuss what i'm doing so they knew who
i was right
but as you as you started speaking up
against i
didn't have plans to speak out i didn't
have plans i'm going to be honest with
you many people think that i have an
agenda i didn't have any plans
i was discovered by look how i'm putting
in this door
you know but american idol australian
idol let's go
i got a call from channel 7
an australia one of the best australian
channels
top channels and they had a program
called today tonight and
apparently they googled imam adelaide
muslim just to get a comment
yeah so they came in wanting a
three-minute
comment on a certain issue and i gave
them a 30-minute talk about the muslim
community and everything and so they
take that and then the director gets in
touch with me
and they're like you know we can do a
lot with what you're saying and you have
this we didn't know
so then i became known in the area
nationally and then internationally and
i had a few heated exchanges
on australian television uh sunrise
yeah were those usually with i suspect
they were probably with
white people on the left is that fair to
say
well or maybe maybe with people more
extreme on the right
well something to that effect we did
have several interviews where
the host was a leftist and
the other guest was an extremist muslim
and they would gang up
on me yeah give him more time and not
give me the right of reply
or that's how you know you're doing
something right yeah or write articles
about me without even
uh asking my opinion or just pops up
article one article two article three so
so were you shocked once you started
talking about these issues
and and the problems that you see within
islam and the solutions that you see
were you shocked where you were getting
comfort from and where you were getting
hatred from
i was absolutely confused confused is
the right word to put it
because on one hand i've got politicians
calling me
telling me that you are an asset you
speak english
you're young you present yourself well
you know how to talk
you're against extremists you love
australia clean record
we need you but not publicly
so that really hurt because what do you
mean not publicly
you want to work with me behind the
scene but you still want to visit the
extremists for votes why wouldn't they
want oh
so that's purely votes because so that
really does tell you about some
demographic stuff i suppose that we'll
talk about
so they'll they'll sit with me privately
and
these meetings aren't uh official
meetings no no
i would actually have my my turban on
the side and we just i'll open some
buttons and we just it was a very
relaxed gathering with this politician
for the record you walked in here
turbineless
and without the robes so just you know
fyi
and it was a very uh friendly gathering
with the
gifts we would exchange gifts but as
soon as
the issue turned public it's like they
don't know me
so that almost gets to the heart of
exactly why the discussion around islam
is so difficult because
every time someone tries to come in and
talk
some sense about the difference between
an ideology and people and all of the
sort of moderate things that i see you
uh talking about all the time you guys
are the ones that get thrown under the
bus there's so many examples of this of
almost every minority that tries to
fight from within
they're the ones that get thrown under
the bus and then all that does is
strengthen the extremists
i think what helped me a lot was the
fact that i had a political advisor
a man who worked in the in the
australian parliament for 40 years
retired now uh australian so
born in australia non-muslim yeah can i
ask you his name just
uh no okay i'm really sorry because i
fear for his safety okay
and basically this man was giving me
advice as to how to handle
the media because look dave you asked me
a question about how i felt
let me just give you one scenario so you
know exactly
what was going through my mind i'm
criticizing extremists on twitter
i get a phone call from the
abc in australia this is the the main
australian broadcasting corporation and
they ask me what is my opinion
about claims that i am aligning myself
with the right
and i said what is the right i did not
know
so i came from a completely conservative
muslim
background now i'm trying to serve
humanity this is my only
agenda to so going against the
extremists and someone's telling me that
there's left in this right now i have to
sit back
yeah and try to understand what's
happening all right so which politician
that i met with was on the right which
one was on the left we're trying to put
everything together or get some
perspective and
that was one of the things that really
confused me so it was really good to
have a political advisor
two and a half years ago because he told
me exactly what was going on
yeah so what about the reaction from
within the community though i would
imagine once you start talking about
these things
often the reaction from within the
community is going to be even worse
because now you're a trader and a
sellout and
the rest of it the community uh reaction
was
very fast and evaporated quickly
because the imam stayed silent
if the leaders carried on then it would
be a different scenario
so what do you make of that i make that
the leaders agree with me because they
still come to my house
and we have dinners and no problem but
they don't want any photos
but i do have photos but i share that
with
the people in government
to know what the progress is with what
i'm doing i'm not a
one-man man who's walking around with
nobody no
muslim leaders come to my house and we
have amazing dinners and we talk about
muslim issues
but the community will reject them if
they know that they have relations with
me
in a way does that type of person
although i can sympathize with their
position
right they don't want to they don't want
their congregation to turn on them or
something like that
but that type of person that gives you
the quiet support
but won't do it publicly isn't it in a
way the most frustrating type of
support i find that i have so many
people that will come up to me public
people people
more famous with plenty more money and
all sorts of things that come up to me
say david you know i really love your
show and i'm sorry i can't tweet about
it i just don't want to get in hot water
or or and i think this is a theme
amongst a lot of the people
that that we're sort of connected to um
it's frustrating but i also appreciate
it because at least i know who's on my
side
and who will not attack me with a fatwa
without me knowing
so it's good i don't appreciate the
silent ones is there a cold fatwa
could we get a fat on both of us right
it would be amazing it's like an episode
of curb your enthusiasm
that would be amazing but it would
certainly pave the way for for other
people to get fatwa so i don't know how
we would feel about that
right right we could deal with it we can
we can yeah yeah um
okay so let's just do a little bit of
sort of
islam 101 and sort of how to talk about
these issues
so when i first sort of became
interested in all of this
most of my audience knows my sort of
political evolution but
it was the night and i i suspect you've
probably seen this that
sam harris the neuroscientist was on
real time with bill maher
and they were talking about the
difference between islam a set of ideas
and muslims as people and that you
shouldn't be prejudiced but you should
be allowed to criticize
ideas and the line that sort of caught
the internet on fire was ben affleck
calling bill maher and sam harris gross
and racist
he said that's gross and racist and for
me and i was a
i was a progressive at the time and the
whole thing
i thought whoa this just captures
everything that i've seen wrong
with my side the inability to deal with
a complex
issue honestly and that the immediate
charge
is you must be racist you must be a
bigot and the rest of it
so first off can you just talk a little
bit about that just how
you can talk about a doctrine any
doctrine but in this case
you know through an islamic lens and
then how
how you can do that but then not be
racist or prejudice towards people okay
that's a very dangerous area to fall
into
because i'm not a political commentator
i am
trying to change the mentality of a
community
at least on a local level socially i
might not be able to change mecca and
change the whole religion
but at least where we live we want to
have a peaceful
community so i'm trying to present
a better example for the moderates or
the vulnerable ones
than the extremist imam in their own
mosque
so it is a very dangerous field because
the moment
you lose their trust you lose a muslim
muslim man's trust or any muslim
individual's trust
if you then recite the quran they'll say
you're lying
because they lost your trust it's
finished they don't trust you anymore
and
i find it very difficult
to get that point across however what i
do is
i use a lot of quotations and so it's
not my words
i quote certain issues and i refer to
certain social events
and i comment on them so i try my best
not to make any statements for myself
because the level of mentality within
the muslim world is that okay
as long as it has a divine coating then
we'll accept it
if it's from tawhidi himself then it's
man-made so if it's divine they also
can't reject it
so i try to use a lot of quotations okay
so can you give me an example of say a
quotation and then how you would
approach it
definitely for example when i speak
against stoning
i can refer to the most sacred book
outside the quran the bukhari
and show that the stoning began when two
monkeys
were throwing rocks at each other in
bukhari
throwing rocks at each other and the
companion of muhammad saw them
and said okay so that that monkey must
be a female and must have cheated on
that male so he's stoning her
so we must apply that and this is the
most sacred book after the quran
and the quran itself does not have a
verse on stoning because a goat ate
that verse so what i do is i bring these
sacred scriptures that speak about
stoning
how it began with monkeys and it beca
and the verse that was supposedly there
was eaten by a goat and i
quickly say well this is a monkey
teaching
it sounds funny as
but the evidence is there yeah um
okay so we can we can talk about these
issues a certain amount of people
all over the map are gonna not be happy
with either one of us
what do you have do you have proof of
some of the inroads that you've been
able to make in terms of de-radicalizing
people the
extremists are so frustrated with me
they're trying to ban me i've got
diplomats in the pakistani government
that try to shut me down
uh are you banned on facebook as we tape
this right now
you were banned a couple days ago can
you just explain to people what you
posted because i retweeted it it's
incredible i didn't i wasn't sure if the
band
the band was still up oh wow hopefully
it's still up by the time we post this
in a couple days but
hopefully not the
amazing song jihad bells jihad bills
jihad all the way
i got that song and i posted it on
facebook and i said i share this song
every christmas because the extremists
don't like it therefore please share it
and it's it's a funny song it ridicules
them for what they're doing
and facebook shut me down for 30 days
and said that was hate speech and that
was it so i find it very ridiculous this
is the ninth time
facebook has blocked me or banned me or
unpublished my page completely in 2018
so it's you know twitter has never
suspended me not once
yeah nothing what do you make of what's
going on with our ability to talk about
these issues
online so you haven't been suspended by
twitter but this has happened a bunch of
times on facebook
uh do you know my friend faizal amutar
so faizal who is one of my best friends
on earth i love the guy i adore him
he has been banned several times for
tweeting out similar
or for posting on facebook several
things like that it's like
do they realize do you think they
realize they're actually emboldening the
extremists the more they
try to take people like you out well
they definitely do because
the extremists only operate as much as
they do because they know
that they can operate with no criticism
or if there is criticism it's only one
or two accounts
that are speaking against them so by
shutting me down
i mean that's a big win for the
jihadists because
let's not forget jihadists use facebook
friend recommendations
to build cyber societies the cyber
caliphate and it's it's a real study
that facebook's been falling
into this trap where it's its website
recommends jihadists to each other based
on the pages they like
yeah so now they have this community and
twitter is the same twitter recommends
friends to each other
so these guys have that advantage
with the help of facebook and twitter
but we don't
when someone likes my page the next
person that comes on
is a right-wing figure so the people say
okay we're not going to like this page
and we're going to unfollow this guy too
yeah it's incredible you're fighting an
ideological war at some level and an
algorithmic war
yes at another level so let's just do
some of the
definitional stuff um so first off
you've mentioned moderate muslims
sometimes so how
what would you say are the categories so
to speak of of muslim people
okay well there's a muslim who believes
in god
believes in the prophet muhammad
believes in the quran
and just an average person
who and this is me speaking in the west
uh
believes that they should pray five
times a day fast in ramadan celebrates
the muslim celebrations
that's about it that's the definition of
a muslim
yeah but can you be less than that and
still be muslim so to speak so so you
couldn't be just
sort of nominally secular muslim where
you don't pray five times every day or
something
by name so you would say that would you
say that's ex-muslim so there is a
i wanted to ask you about the ex-muslim
community also but so you would say
that's just you would say that's
actually not muslim that's just sort of
look a muslim the term muslim
is taken from islam which means
submission so when it's a verb
a muslim is a man who's submitting so
you're every day you're praying so
you are upholding that name of being a
muslim if you don't pray
then you're just muslim by name you're
not an actual
muslim right you're not an ex-muslim
because you haven't denounced the
religion
you're just missing prayers or drinking
alcohol
right so do you have any idea the
numbers of that amount i would imagine
in the west
that that's probably a very large
percentage of muslims
the majority of muslims believe in god
and and uh
and pray and there are also muslims that
believe in god allah believe in muhammad
but don't pray
right so i wouldn't say that's an issue
for us they can
pray or not pray whenever they like for
me it's the more extremist ones
and then trying to differentiate between
the moderate and the extremists right
okay so we've got sort of just the ones
by name only i get the ones who let's
say aren't practicing but but still
are they were born muslim they're muslim
then the ones who are not practicing
are the ones the west refers to as
moderates right so that's where i was
trying to get with this to understand
what your definition of moderate is
it's the ones who don't practice and by
not practicing i mean
the other laws of islam so for example
the
the stoning the killing the reporting on
people who
break the blasphemy law issues like that
people who just don't care just want to
go to work nine to five come back raise
a family
you know live life go on holidays yeah
parents were muslim we were born muslim
but that's about it
these guys are the ones who are referred
to as moderates
but they're not really moderates the
moderate
is the the ex the the
the muslim that is conservative but
wishes to ban
certain uh teaching certain verdicts
they are the moderates so the moderate
is the one who's sort of staying
within the religion and and fighting the
extreme parts of the religion
whether it be personally on a family
level not raising their children in
extremist mosques
those are the moderates okay and then
you obviously include yourself in that
well uh well i can see why this would be
a tough question i don't
believe in in something called the
mother of islam now
just for the viewers to not get confused
yeah i'm answering your question
based on what society and what islam
says
my personal opinion could be another
thing
so you might want to ask me what my
opinion is on this issue i don't believe
there's a mother
let's pretend i asked you your opinion
there is no moderate to
islam islam is is islam and
you're either a reformist a reformer a
reformed person
or you're still a muslim the muslims who
don't
chop the hand of the thief and don't
stone and and don't
uh you know apply the violence of sharia
law
they they've diverted away from the core
beliefs of islam
so in a weird way you're an imam
who also you obviously have a great
affinity's not the right word
you have a great respect i suppose for
for the ex-muslims in a way
the ex-muslims have every right
to be where they are yeah because now is
the worst time to be a muslim
and when a muslim has
a problem or is facing a problem whether
it be inheritance
financial issues abuse at home
divorce after being married off you know
at a very young age
they don't find the person who listens
to them
the majority of imams in mosques
have zero qualifications when it comes
to counseling when it comes to solving
real life problems they only know how to
talk when it's against israel against
the jews
and to play the victim card and
basically spread news about what they're
doing in society
so the ex-muslims the majority of them
leave the religion
because number one they really feel it's
not for them anymore
and the people who pave the way for them
right i do know that some people read
richard dawkins or read certain books
and then change their religion or leave
religion completely
but isis makes more ex-muslims than any
intellectual
in the west so
to if we want to blame ex-muslim for
being ex-muslim
it's the most the fundamentalist muslims
that made them ex-muslim
they are the ones who are making them
leave the religion and that's completely
contrary to what the media would portray
about this they would say it's it's
that if you talk about any of this
you're driving people to become
extremists
which as many people call it this is the
soft bigotry of low expectations if i
was to say anything that might offend
you
you would automatically become an
extremist which is such a horrific way
of
of viewing another human being you know
is there something that i could say to
you that somehow you might end up
blowing me up
nothing if you were to kill me and i'd
come back to life i'd still hug you yeah
seriously i'd still shake your head
you've got nothing to worry about
brother
okay so let's just do a little bit more
of the deaf okay so wait so we have
sort of the ex-muslims and the nominal
muslim then then the moderate that you
say is not
really a thing actually then can you
sort of explain
uh islamists and jihadists okay and if
there's anything else that i missed
within that
islamist is an individual that believes
in
preaching and spreading and expanding
islam and the message of islam
through militant means so
they would spread islam by the sword and
now the tactics are a bit different now
it's getting through congress
so before it was by the sword now it's
getting themselves into parliament and
then making laws that act as the sword
the islamophobia law in canada and 103.
yeah so an an islamist would silence
you just to spread his agenda
that's different from a muslim a muslim
would say okay this is the quran
i believe allah is the right god i
believe islam is true
accept it you don't accept it you're not
going to be saved good night good night
that's basically a muslim
an islamist will actually go the extra
mile
of kidnapping someone because they drank
alcohol and whipping them
because they believe that is the right
thing to do we've seen across europe
statues are being destroyed because it's
not allowed in islam
so that's an islamist an islamist
organization would be hamas hamas is an
islamist organization
that did terrorist doings it's
responsible for terrorist activities so
then it became a terrorist organization
but its ideology is an islamist ideology
so two-state solution is not an option
they need to be eliminated because our
message is the right one
that's an islamist mentality
now the other person or the the other
group of people
would be the fundamentalists a
fundamentalist muslim
wants to preserve uh the message of
prophet muhammad
and live like muhammad the same way he
lived so if
the reports say muhammad had a short
pants because his pants
would stop to his ankle they'd go to
university harvard university
and with their ankles sticking out right
so if there was no deodorant in mecca
we're not going to use deodorant if the
if muhammad never trimmed his beard with
a blade then we're not going to use a
blade on ours
that's a fundamentalist and these guys
will always take the side of the
islamist
rather than the moderate and also
moderate is just a politically
created term it's a political term to
differentiate
yeah but at the end of the day i don't
believe there's
a muslim or you're not and then there
are levels in in faith
as to how deep you are and how how much
into the religion you are
so where does the jihadist fit into that
because i thought that was a little bit
of your definition
of a islamist because of the because of
the use of violence
okay the islamist isn't always a
jihadist
an islamist can be someone who believes
in the ideology of spreading islam
by violence who believes that's the
right way
that's how religion should develop but
they don't actually
go and fight you know who these people
are the majority of the imams
so they're sitting in their mosques
recruiting sending people to isis but
they're not jihadists the imam is
responsible
for the jihadist going and joining isis
so he's an islamist and he would send
the
the islamist congregation
to then become jihadist so this is when
when people talk about the
radicalization that's happening in
mosques in the west
you you believe that to be a real thing
of course it is a real thing and it's
something we battle every single day
what so what if i was to go into one of
these mosques
right what would i be hearing well
firstly because of your beard you'd be
welcome i'd be welcome i'd
have to lengthen this a little bit okay
yes you'd be welcomed
okay and a fundamentalist mosque would
they would definitely frown upon you if
you had shaved your beard completely
so be it you'd be welcome so if you
don't have a beard you actually can't
even go in
no you can they'll just tell you why
what's wrong are you a woman
yeah are you a jew why because
the reports say that the jews that came
to fight muhammad
had no beards on it was a sign of going
to war
in in arabia the sign of going to war
would be to shave your head
the jews in arabia would shave their
beards so then you can tell
who's who in the battle jesus so
jesus yeah so the muslims kept their
beards yeah okay
okay so it's not a criteria there are
many reformers who don't have beer
there's no big deal
i grow this out it's a week from now i
say to you
mom get me to one of these mosques i
want to know what's going on
i walk in with you let's say on a friday
prayer
yeah just tell me what what what is
actually being spoke of
that is the place from where it goes
from
an islamist ideology to a fundamentalist
ideology what are people hearing
okay well firstly it depends on the
speaker it depends on the image
there are islamist imams who say
in close circles what they will not say
on the pulpits
because of the laws in the west and then
there are imams who would go
on there and say things nobody could
ever imagine would ever be said
in the history of islam on the pulpit
they would just say it so there were two
in the west
some of them are doing this in the i
mean we see this out of canada a lot
yeah
just these incredibly awful things that
people that they're saying
memory has a wonderful archetype of all
of these issues
youtube is another great source and the
issue is they
the mosque records the imam and uploads
it
on youtube so it's nothing being
discovered they
they know that the world is going to
react this way and they still continue
to produce this content and now they're
speaking in english
which makes my job a lot easier because
i have to translate sometimes but now
they're just
saying it in english yes we want to be
heard then we want to
concur and so when there's when i see
these videos and memory
does a great job of the translations
when i see these videos but
let's say the ones that aren't
translated from canada for example
they want that message to get out of the
mosque like you would think that's
contrary
to what they would want you'd think it's
like you'd want to keep it sort of
radicalized within so you can put a good
face on things
but you're saying when they're talking
about this and that with the jews and
the gays and
this and that and the other thing you
think they they actually want that to
get out there because they're the ones
putting it out
yes and also there's a concept of the
one muslim nation
and it's called the muslim ummah islam
the islamic nation now what it is
is basically a muslim is a citizen of
two or more nations one the nation they
live in
america australia uh the uk
and the second one is the nation of
islam not
farah but the actual islamic nation
so if the mufti in mecca issues a fatwa
an islamist sitting in l.a would come in
a terrorist attack
you see that connection yeah so when
they so if salman rushdie's at starbucks
yes and somewhere in iran is a fatwa
they'll get him here
there's a link and no other religion has
this power
unless it's an organized organization
that targets people and sends
hitmen but no other religion has this
power and imam in mecca
would would say that the jews are the
enemy
or that the christians are the enemy
knowing 100 that there will be a muslim
who would go and commit a terrorist
attack he doesn't even have to look for
him he doesn't need to do anything he
just knows there's a muslim
who will get this and will do the job no
other religion has this
and we see it several times where
in russia they killed the a uh
i think it was uh sorry in turkey
i think it was a russian ambassador was
shot dead oh yeah
there's a video of it yeah yeah just
right in the museum or something he was
supposed to protect him and he said
for syria and we see this every single
month an act doesn't go by without
someone in in the west
commanding a terrorist attack and saying
this is for syria this
is for iraq what's that link and this
confuses our intelligence departments
they've never seen anything like it so
when we're speaking about imams
uploading videos online they're actually
contributing to that platform of the
islamic nation
whoever is out there this is our message
so i know you're a free speech guy
because i see you tweeting about it all
the time and then you're exercising your
free speech here it's a beautiful thing
what should be done no i don't mean just
from
you know the inside conversation say you
meeting with a more fundamentalist imam
and trying to
you know get him back let's say towards
the center or something
but what should be done by these states
what should canada what should the
united states what should australia be
doing
because they're using the the freedoms
of the west against themselves
i mean this is as difficult to free
speech topic as there is for the for the
true free speech people
they're fighting for democratic rights
to be applied for the extremists for the
islamists
when the islamist doesn't believe in
democracy they will use democracy to
destroy democracy and then
establish their own belief system now
what can we do i think
and i say this all the time when when
i'm having dinner with
a politician or a premier or anyone and
i say your political party
is finished you guys are infiltrated and
if you email me i'll send you reports
about one
or two of your candidates and what their
backgrounds are like
and they they remain speechless and i'm
not speaking liberal i'm speaking
conservative party
i'm speaking uh parties who you know we
have hope in okay these guys will
seriously
serve uh the cause of national security
will you know tighten
uh the situation at the borders won't
let these jihadists come in
uh refugees who end up being jihadists
we've had them in australia
so these guys are being infiltrated so
number one what we can do so what does
that mean they're being infiltrated
meaning
meaning that there are actual operatives
within the political parties i mean i
just had bridget gabriel on who who
talks
a lot about the the muslim brotherhood's
long plan yes that this is an
actual plan yes it's one of the main
plans
to infiltrate political parties and then
make
their way into uh positions where they
can change or make the law
and we've seen this numerous times i
mean my book i speak about
a lady khatib i mean she became
well she's deceased now she passed away
but she she
actually said that her long-term goal is
to make
all of america muslim and she was
getting grants
from the american government she was
overseeing educational curriculums
and and you see this i mean even in the
united states i'm i'm not totally sure
this is her name elan omar is that her
name
the representative in minnesota yes who
just got elected
and you know they found old tweets of
hers where she's saying you know
the jews or israel has pulled the wool
over something and allah has to take
care of this
and then the entire time that she was
being elected she kept saying she's
against boycotting israel
the day she gets elected now she's for
it so so this is not
just pie in the sky stuff that you're
talking about
everything you see in the muslim world
when it comes to politics
is all studied is strategic it's all
planned
well funded well organized and they know
exactly what to do and when to do it
all the media that's going on now
against the
the organization such as care
they do no harm to care whatsoever care
has a clear vision
and they are reaching their goals
because there are loopholes and there
are cracks within
the system and they're equivalent in
canada they're equivalent in australia
and these you know these loopholes
within
the government keep getting bigger and
bigger as these guys get elected
and i don't want to scare your viewers
but all i have to say is these people
are very smart people
they're not what the media says that
when they
actually attack and then they're
mentally ill or these people are
uh minorities not they're very strategic
and they're very very smart which is why
intelligence services around the world
need hundreds of millions of dollars
just to keep up
with what these guys are doing that we
need these resources to understand
how they operate and they keep learning
and they're getting better and better
what do you make of the uh
the progressive alliance seemingly with
islamists i i to me this is like the
biggest piece of this that you've got
certain pieces
pieces of the left that are just useless
idiots basically they're useful idiots
not useless they're useful because
they're allowing these people to attain
power
in the name of tolerance and it's like
well you guys will just be the last ones
to be beheaded i mean that's really the
way i see this thing playing out
first when i was a fundamentalist
islamist someone who rejected the west
rejected dialogue with the west my best
friends from the outside world
you know and i wouldn't say they were
friends who i knew personally but the
people who i considered
our friends our allies were the leftists
so when i was a fundamentalist imam
sitting in iraq or
in iran and i'm on social media
there were certain people i liked
politicians i liked
jeremy corbyn a hero
people like that yeah hillary clinton
every muslim
every extremist muslim in the united
states votes for hillary clinton
this is a fact i'm not saying all of
them vote but those who do vote vote
hillary they would never vote republican
right so can you explain that connection
there
there's a common agenda it's very common
i mean
you take a look at what these guys are
doing uh it's it's very common
look most extremist muslims just want to
operate
who's going to give them that free room
to breathe
they'll vote for that person and hillary
and obama these guys they
funded isis they funded isis they funded
the mujahideen the jihadists these
rebels who killed my family
and these guys fund them so the
extremist at the end of the day is not
seen as
a threat by the democratic party they
visit them every ramadan and they sit
with them every ramadan and they
you know they welcome each other so what
do you think okay so
i'll go with you on that but what do you
think then is in the mind of hillary or
obama or any of these other lower level
politicians that then i would say again
are useful
idiots basically they don't understand
the threat that you're laying out here
do you or do they are they you know like
what what do you think is actually going
on in the mind of hillary when
when she's doing these things well she
and we don't even have to make it about
her so specifically but any of these
people
no she understands the threat and so do
many people like her they know the
threat of what they're doing
i think they're just greedy because they
know they can't be touched
so she's protected she doesn't care
about anybody else
it's greed but that protection doesn't
always last right i mean
this is a fool's game right it doesn't
last but i mean
i think she's guaranteed for the rest of
her life she's going to have that
protection at least because you know
in iraq we had the same situation how
did isis get in
isis got into iraq because certain
politicians played
the diversity game you know why have
borders with saudi arabia
why have a wall just let the deserts be
open
and then these cars came in from around
the world then they took over
uh 40 minutes away from baghdad i mean
then politicians when their family
members were being killed they they woke
up
so maybe that that's what it takes that
you be
you experience the threat of
uh jihad personally then you'll
understand where imam tahiti
is coming from and people like dave
rubin who understand what imam tahiti is
saying
maybe some people will wake up but then
again that's another world of politics
so let's talk about immigration a little
bit because it's been sort of a thread
through this
your first strong border protection
i mentioned to you right before we
started i was in london a couple
months ago and i hadn't been there for
quite some time before that i've been
there twice this year and the first time
i was there
one of the things that was shocking to
me it's just it's just viscerally
shocking and it has nothing to do with
bigotry or hatred or anything else
is that i was in you know the harrods
area right in the sort of center of
london
and the amount of women that i saw in
burqas i mean only eyes
that's it now i have no problem with
those people
individually of course but seeing this
amount i mean i'm talking
it seemed like at points 20 or 30
percent of the women
now if they if it if i had seen 30 of
the women dressed in traditional mormon
clothing
or dressed as orthodox jews i would have
also thought there's something strange
going on here let's put it that way
that's what i just like
there's something odd going on here can
you just talk about that related to
western countries and then how that's
related to immigration
very simple you see how i had to even
ask the question in a way that's like
i'm apologizing
just for seeing something it's like it's
pathetic yeah
it's very simple the west has become
weaker they've become stronger
they're telling you this is the norm in
fact this is the encouraged norm this is
how we're going to dress you're going to
look at us and you're going to turn away
if you don't like it
that's basically it that's what's
happening now are these people
extremists of course i'm not saying
every lady that wears a burka is an
extremist
what i'm saying is because you know
this is between us on camera yeah yeah
yeah
don't worry it's just going to youtube
yes
you know some of the filthiest women
to ever exist are ones that wear burqas
seriously hookers uh they wear burqas
because they don't want them
their faces to be known and
you know now in baghdad from the reports
that come
because you know i speak to officials
they tell us that
they have a problem with prostitution
and the women are wearing
burqas and they want to stand out from
the other woman that are wearing burqa
so what they do is they flip their
attire inside out but it's all black but
all you have to do is focus on that
thread
is that inside out right so an inside
albuquerque
prostitute exactly in baghdad and some
air
some muslim areas if a lady went in
there with a burka they
know she's up to something so this is an
islamophobia
right this is muslim areas oh what's
what's she up to so it's none of that oh
i wear it to preserve my modesty no
one's going to hit on me on the street
no cat calling no
in fact some guys go out there just to
look for these women
because they know she's out for business
yeah no not all of them
but this does exist
for the women who live in the west who
wear burqas
there are several types of women one
one that's forced by her husband
the second one and the second type is
the type that would divorce her husband
if he told her to take it off
and the third one would be someone who's
just trying to
fit in with all of this we are the
rebels in society
we are the real muslims that's basically
my analysis of the situation yeah
do the average lefty that used to be
your your ally when you were more
extreme so to speak
do you think they realize that this set
of ideas is so
in direct conflict with the rest of
their ideas the rest of their ideas
about tolerance and were for gays and
minorities and women and all of these
things
that they've aligned themselves with
with an ideology if you were to look at
it in their pyramid
they've put islam really at the top of
their pyramid because they believe it's
a brown person's religion
which of course is is a racist notion in
itself because a religion is not of a
skin color
um but do you think they even realize
like now i'm not talking about
say the islamist what they realize their
alliance is the other way around
do you think these people have any sense
of what's going on here i think what's
happening
now is that loyalty has shifted from
being loyal to your country
and to your people to being loyal to
your boss and to your company
so i've seen journalists who would write
wonderful articles about me
the moment they get a job in a
left-leaning
outlet it's like i'm a [ __ ] i'm the
worst person
they've ever known and the contradiction
remains online like what happened here
i'm
i'm someone who's going to influence the
australia
and i'm a peaceful guy and they welcome
me and here
i'm a fraud who should be silenced don't
give him the megaphone
so you see i think loyalty falls in
companies no more in
in country or faith or family yeah can
you talk a little bit about the sort of
unique way that islam is designed to
spread
so are you familiar with dr bill warner
who does political islam.com so
one of the things that he said when i
had him on i think this is probably over
three years ago
that i thought was interesting he said
that religions are designed to spread
differently
so judaism for example it's very hard to
convert you have to do a lot to convert
but if you want to get out
you just basically say i'm not a jew
every jew would be like ah you're still
a jew and then that's it
where islam it's very easy to get in
right you just have to recite something
very quickly
and it's almost impossible to get out
because then you're an apostate
so now we can we can kill you so he said
it's actually
a virus is is very easy to attain and
very difficult
to eliminate so that's what he was
comparing to i thought it was an
interesting
analogy okay um for
me personally the way i see it is if
islam is going to grow it has to go in
the right direction
because i believe muslims will always be
converting people and there'll be people
always converting to islam
so i don't believe religion can be
stopped at all
or eliminated i mean look at judaism
they never had a government to protect
them for thousands and thousands of
years
everyone was trying to kill them and did
in fact kill them they've been
butchered in the millions but they still
they're still around it's hard it's not
it's almost impossible
to eradicate a religion it doesn't work
like that
so that's my take my position so i don't
see it as a virus
i just believe people will always have
certain opinions and
and change religions what i do
acknowledge is the fact that islam is
very strategic
in recruiting adherence to its belief
system
and this isn't all islamic schools of
thought but the majority of them
so the majority and mainstream do
actually have a strategy
and it's called through dawa dawa what
dawa is
they go out to the streets and they're
basically selling religion they'll sully
religion
and in return they'll give you heaven
paradise in the hereafter
that's the the basic transaction and
you know there's an audience for
everything this is a fact and many
people
do embrace islam because of the promises
that they get i mean if you're a
businessman
and you're stopped by one of these
stalls they'll tell you
there's so much wealth waiting for you
one prayer will build you five castles
if you're a farmer they'll tell they'll
promise you
massive farms in paradise if they know
that you like women
they'll promise you plenty of women like
the jihadist 72 virgin issue
72 virgin seems like a bit much
no the actual teachings say
each one of these 72 virgins comes with
her aids
so it's actually more than 72. and the
the actual number 72
or 70 in the arabic language just means
a lot it means unlimited oh is that
right
i've told you a million times okay okay
all right that's good to know
so it's not actually 72 okay um
and it's not raisins either many people
say it's not because
the islamic books describe their hair
their eyes
and if one hairband was to fall on
planet earth the perfume would
be smelt by everyone so there are
descriptions that these are actual women
not raisins so the strategy of islam
spreading
is very unique in a sense that their
unity
uh in in their theology is unbreakable
it's impossible i mean a muslim would
unite with a muslim
against a christian against an atheist
even if he knows his brother and faith
is wrong so then how are you a muslim
and that's the thing when you ask him
as a muslim they'll say no you ask the
shia are the sunnis muslim they'll say
not real muslims then the ahmadiyya will
say
both of these guys are not muslim i'm
the real muslim
and then both the shia and the sunni
will unite against the media and say he
is not the real muslim
so it's a struggle within islam itself
it's a problem and they fall into many
contradictions because of this because
muslims kill muslims
every day muslim governments bombing
other muslim governments
so right i mean what's going on with
saudi arabia and yemen right yeah which
nobody talks about of course because we
don't know how to frame it properly
so we just wait for something to happen
with israel basically and then it's like
oh well now we can
we got good guys and bad guys it's easy
so all right so two more questions for
you so
one where do you what do you think it is
about you
about the guy i'm sitting across from
right now that gives you the sort of
bravery to talk about this this is this
is i mean that's why when you first came
on the scene and everyone was like talk
to this guy
i was hesitant because i was like i just
i just don't know enough that i'd a i
don't want the wool pulled over my eyes
but b
you know as your critics will say
there's fame to gain out of this there
is all of this other
uh bounty to be had but so what is it
about you
that makes you do this i'm nobody
special
i swear i am nobody special i'm just a
regular guy
who grew up in a muslim family was
trained in iran
life put me in this position ordained as
a scholar
came back to australia started meeting
with politicians
it worked out really well more
politicians started inviting me
we started working with parliaments
advising senate
and i have a twitter account that i'm
active on i have a foundation and
organization
basic stuff and i speak out
only because i've always been outspoken
about every when i was an islamist i was
an outspoken islamist
so let's put it that way what an
outspoken islamist sound like
you don't want to hear it it's horrible
yeah i was outspoken
um i used to flagellate i don't know if
you've seen my pictures
no but you so you actually used to do it
yeah
i was kind of oh wait can you explain
what that is i would cover myself
in my own blood absolute flagellation
so you know i'm i'm not a convert into
the religion
yeah yeah i've come from that whole
lineage of lifestyle
you got cred yeah but people usually ask
me
uh what red pilled you and because this
isn't politics this is religion
i just don't know how to answer that but
i think the best way to put it is
that i have always been outspoken
and i'm not afraid in fact i
am afraid of the fact that i'm not
afraid
because i can get myself into serious
trouble i've said certain things
in front of certain people that i i've
had to leave the country the same
afternoon yeah well your
your twitter twitter bio used to be yes
something to the do you know what
exactly this is one day
one day you will hear that i have been
killed and the news will speak about it
that was my first twitter bio and then i
changed it
simply because i had a meeting with
state intelligence
and they said you know what you could be
giving ideas to certain people
so remove it so i put peace advocate
things like that
but i do have a you know a great
security
team and i'm very grateful for yeah
all right so my last question is this
paint me two roads of the future
give me two pictures of the future i
want the
the future that you want to build
and then i want the future if that does
not get built what does that look like
so you can do either one first
the future i want to build focuses on
the west and the west alone
the middle east isn't in my area anymore
because me having this interview
something like this in the middle east
would see me killed the same week
so the best way to reach the middle east
is through social media and i've got my
accounts in arabic i've got accounts in
different languages
where i have translators that do that
for me but
my main vision and my ef
effort and energy goes into
the west and i
would like to see all
islamist extremist centers shut down
the people who are fundamentalist and
have been sponsored by terrorist
organizations such as care
to lose their positions in in government
i would like to see a honorable leader
of a country
that cracks down on these extremists
on the other hand i would like to see
the
so-called moderates or just the regular
muslims
speaking out more and their imams being
more vocal against
extremists and have
this unity as a society
you could be jewish i could be muslim
our friend could be christian
and we could just sit down and have a
meal together
shake hands go to you know a match
watch a match together watch a movie no
problem in that which people are doing
every day in the west
yeah by the way we shouldn't forget that
right it's like we are doing that
exactly so after this interview i'll go
back to australia
and i go back into the muslim community
i don't go back
to meeting with jews and christians i do
that in my interfaith
work but i actually live amongst the
muslim community
so i would like to see that muslim
community embracing the larger
community in the west that's uh
my vision because then we can work on
establishing peace and building better
relations
and basically uniting with the with the
rest of the world against the extremists
within our own religion that's my vision
if that doesn't work out i was gonna say
we should have done this the other way
because now you're gonna end up ending
on
on the bad note so i'll try to figure
out a way to get us to some nice ending
here yes
if that doesn't work out then i believe
we have to unite as
because there will always be muslims who
have conservative
views do you know how many muslims vote
for trump
many they fled from the rulers who trump
is now putting in line
so they would vote for trump just for
that very reason that they know
that their rulers back home can't start
war
with other countries who are allies with
america
so many muslims vote for trump well that
that also is the ultimate irony of the
alliance with the left because it's like
you're taking a group of people
who are inherently conservative who hold
conservative religious
values and then you're allowing them
with people that hold none of those
values and they're going please join us
for now
yes i think if if my vision of
the west doesn't end up being successful
then we need to unite as the
the revisionists reformist muslims
who are completely against what's
happening unite with the jews
with the christians let's put far left
far right
aside and let's just speak as humans who
are concerned about national security
we need to unite on a professional level
it's not enough to speak on youtube and
and to tweet this isn't enough for me
which is why i go and i sit with
politicians because
i want to get something done so we need
to unite either now
or unite in a much more global
style in the future to end on a positive
note i'll tell you this
the islamists are worried now
maybe not showing it too much because
they're getting
people into congress and people into
parliaments but they are worried they're
they've lost a lot of territory the
caliphate that they dreamed of
they have lost isis they've lost a lot i
mean
the united arab emirates is shutting
them down uh austria
shut down 60 deported 60 imams
back to turkey i mean we are
doing things that harm them and harm
their
you know their their agenda of death
basically
and we're doing them in large uh
portions so in portions they can't uh
accept
60 imams vanish from the country in one
day
that's a big loss for them yeah so we
are pushing back
i believe as as a as a society or as a
global society
against the extremists but i think it's
it's a slow
way to the the finishing point and we
will win at the end of the day i do know
that eventually people would just get
fed up with the extremists
and unite with these reformists and just
get them out of the society i don't know
how maybe in 100 years i don't know
but it's going to be really bad the way
we win will be really bad it will not be
peaceful and it's
i really hope that we can pave the way
for a much more peaceful ending
but i'll just say this every time i came
on australian television
i have a police officer that that tells
me you know imam
i've been sensing this every time you go
out there speaking
we get more applications for firearms
because they believe the invasion is
coming
so then i i started to tone it down a
little bit yeah
but i still want to say the truth and i
wish for a peaceful ending that's
basically it isn't it weird how you just
have to live your life and do what you
think is right
at all times i remember when i first
started talking about this stuff and i
was just a little worried about
security and things i i said to do you
know dennis prager yes
i said to dennis prager i asked him
about just security because just any of
any of my friends in this world that
talk about this stuff i was just asking
and i said to dennis uh you know what do
you do about security and he told me
some things that i can't repeat but then
he goes
but at the end of the day when it's your
time to go it's your time to go
i thought i'm a little younger than you
i'm not quite ready for that yet well
listen
you have an ally in me and i hope i hope
i hope i hope we helped
spread a little bit of what i know
you've made your life about
and uh you know hopefully there's a way
that it doesn't get that bad before it
gets better i suppose we shall see
definitely thank you so much for having
me yeah and i'm sorry we can't hang out
tonight because i would have loved to
but i'm a little crazy at the moment
and for more on imam tuiti follow him on
twitter
before he's banned at imam of peace
[Music]